as a 47 year old watching how many
parents demonized our youth don't get
into rap don't get into punk rock don't
get into video games I mean do you
understand how many parents were
mortified that their kids wanted to cook
that was the help meanwhile what
happened on the back end of that was the
explosion of the Food Network and famous
chefs and like skateboarding I remember
when I was in second third grade
exploded and like that's not a
profession Tony Hawk video games and
profession booger ninja your job is to
help your kids find their life's task
and that might be something that makes
no sense to you that might be something
that scary to you that's weird to you
and when they find the thing that lights
them up your job is to encourage that
facilitate it give them the kinds of
lessons that allow that to be their
thing